sono tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigente ed oggi siamo
tornati sud redoubt non so se ve lo
ricordate io purtroppo me lo ricordo
tanto in partenza c'è quest'ombra
bellissima che mi sta fissando fantasia
interpro filename gesù è uscita ragazzi
il continuo incredibile perché era la
vita che non usciva da new game aironi
ma sempre gesù sempre di gesù erano
rimasti ragazzi che avevano combattuto
contro quella tipa bruttissima ma
ricordo brent orribile ma ci stanno e
modelle di victoria's secret fantastico
chiarimenti questa la location vecchia
ragazzi metteranno veramente [ __ ] ecco
la [ __ ] stocco la addio
ragazzi io non ho dormito una settimana
e mezza e quindi magari evitate questi
primi piani su ste bocce quello va bene
proprio magari quello che esce dallo
specchio nota zia come stai
aiko venga anche mi sveglio così la
domenica mattina dopo il sabato sera
insomma ngo che cazzo fatto bella li
perfetto ragazzi siamo partiti da una
vita che non gioca dried out quindi non
mi ricordo più
e queste che sui miei compagni di classe
con il ritardo ragazzo che mi guardi con
quello sguardo sempre sexy mi hai fatto
a cadere i tuoi piedi bel maschio
l'obiettivo ragazzi quando si crepa va
era quali andare verso la luce quindi io
vado verso la luce gesù prendimi che
bello tra doubt keepers of the dark
la novità di sto capitol hill redoubt
che è molto più simpatica la location
caos non fa vj sei per caso un guerriero
jedi posso scattarsi una foto del culo
lamento su facebook senza updown lo devo
infilarti quel telefono nelle natiche
mi scusi devo non mi saltare addosso è
che bello 60 che cazzo fa è innamorato
della scopa regalo
ho capito che in tempi di guerra ogni
buco trincea come che poi guarda la
scopa come se fosse tua moglie
tentazione io io posso farle questa foga
che pensa che posso farti questa
bellissima foto in via alla tua moglie
così almeno lei vede che la tradisce il
brutto stronzo ma parla sto tizio le
candele non sono qui solo per
decorazione riguardato ragazzi ci sono i
sottotitoli che lui sta parlando ma lui
dice solo ha detto solo però nel
sottotitolo è scritta una poesia quindi
non so come sia possibile
mi ha detto che le candele non sono solo
decorazioni si sicuro di voler entrare
qua dentro
no però questo punto entriamo che
cazzate voti bella stanza sempre
contento solo di trovare posti nuovi
ma è un hotel 5 stelle salve a samar
sdraia a farm anche bob già che ci sei
giorno zia e allora questa è la postura
sbagliata mamma dice sempre stai dritta
con la schiena
qualcosa mi dice che sarà tango su
facebook si incazza regala come quindi
non lo faccio giorno io vorrei capire
dove sto andando questa la scuola e la
location dell'altra volta ragazzi solo
che pieno di manichini a carissimo senza
motivo se qualcosa si muove per caso
giuro che se faccio un salto incredibile
tanto ragazzi che c'era un cinghiale
l'altra volta una tranquilla so che sei
in una posizione poco cristiana quindi
non ti faccio foto giorno
vabbè mica ragazza è tutta sta gente è
un concerto the one direction ed ha reso
le azie
non si è rotta in pubblico e brutti
stronzi chi cazzo aiutato chi è quel
lurido stronzo che card statuetta che ha
appena firmato la sua condanna a morte
salve devo prendere questa cosa scusa
get your sasuke today gli uomini ti
adoreranno la fortuna ti ringrazierà va
bene però non ho capito cosa mi serve un
giorno un bel culetto
vendo su ebay oddio così c'è una tipa
suoi che c'è una tipa qua dentro
salve ed evo devo c'è uno specchio là in
fondo posso parlare con te senza che mi
stanziando ti servono gli al cosa ci
vuoi fare cogliano non ridere non ridere
non ho detto niente anzi e mi sa che io
mi sono risvegliato con la botta però te
non sei ancora un bria gadù posso
parlarti home i saltimbocca amica ti sto
gioco ci sono le grafiche che non mi
caga giovai testa e merda fatto la foto
no no no scherzavo schiaccia al giorno
l'anti tagua purissimo o porca [ __ ] ma
sbattuto al muro ed sbattere io grossi
non posso farlo adesso che vuole vardar
canoa seriamente parte che ci si scalza
metti un paio di ciabatte via veloce
parquet ma che è un esorcista
ok forse sono forze sono salvo no non
sono salvo manco per il bene salve c'è
una tipa che mi sta seguendo il signor
sing sing me lamela può fermare lei la
fermi lei porca [ __ ] ecco sto cadavere
qua è più bello di te luca poi dalla
vita mia ha atto nel tempo libero servi
cadaveri ma che ne so io ognuno ha i
suoi gusti ma di sicuro il più educativo
guardare sto cadavere che pomeriggio 5
con barbara d'urso per carità
insomma è finito stava pubblicitaria
ciao ragazze porti i cadaveri c'è
qualcos'altro in sto gioco di divertente
che hanno aggiunto tipo un motorino a
caso dentro la da scuola no perché sul
letto
chi è che ride io non ho capito che cosa
serve a letto grossi come c'è la tipa a
quella di prima che mi segue
ma ti fa più letto stava re va beh non
lo so è poi raga dipende dalla situation
e vorrei offrire un drink ma mi sa che
più briaca le prima non c'è una bella
risata e zio nota che arrivi perché c'è
un lampione del dentro una scuola
spiegatemi ma la razzia non accarezzare
motorino non lo puoi rimorchiare un
pezzo di ferro e io di ferro chanel 3
con odio saltata
se presa bene dove non alzi il letto
della dove vai
era mi siedo vivaio suk a poco se la
tira ma di quelle che se la tira manco
fosse volo pamela anderson ma sai che ti
dico
ma va va angulo me ne vado avanti io da
solo ma chi ha bisogno della patata così
chi ci ha bisogno ma perché nella scuola
ci sono degli alberi dei lampioni dei
motorini per l'hanno presa per un parco
sta scuola bello devo raccogliere tutti
gli aghi
ce l'hai su spotify sa canzone insieme
ma dove dove dove sta andando rimasta
dei problemi facciamo così ti faccio
vedere un film che ti rispecchia
tantissimo si chiama una notte da leoni
sono dei tipi che si risvegliano non
sanno manco che cazzo è successo più o
meno lato situation cretini comunque ho
trovato degli aghi se ti interessano
kagami perché non mica gli ho capito che
ci deve essere la free enzo al però non
è proprio necessaria scommettete che va
nella stanza dove cesta letto st sporca
shaun
lo sapevo lo sapevo brutta sporcacciona
agricola mamma e zia te lo dico ma che
vuoi prendere in giro ha sì ho capito
che sono in friends on tanto ti sei
messa a dormire con la candela svegliata
non a norma non la pubblico è inutile
che ti incazzi ti giuro che non la
pubblico salve mi scusi lei devo neanche
lei posso fare formale già su facebook
ma don mica c'è proprio gli occhi
sensibilizzino neanche flash e tanto sta
scrivania è più ordinata della mia ci
vuole poco è per carità di dio però
questi mister ma porca [ __ ] mi son
caduti in mano
[Musica]
rihanna sei tu eri deposta cosa che ridà
ancora non l'ho capita lega prove bella
[ __ ] cuore lo sapevo io è lo sappia
prima o poi lo sapevo che qualcuno mi
usciva così brutta [ __ ] brava brava
obiettivo updated ragazzi che cos'è
cos'è cos'è ma per cosa per quale motivo
ti stai muovendo turno andare di qua
brutta [ __ ] e niente regali mi
chiudono le strade fantastico di un'asse
di legno a caso è la faina rincoglionita
ma pesante proprio cercando di capire da
dove arriva la canzone cosa se mostra
tipo subito eccola st brutta [ __ ]
[ __ ] al cuore o non tenga samuel eto'o
ha detto ti ho detto niente di brutto a
favore sculetta st [ __ ] quindi lei
si nasconde io devo trovarla nelle stata
ma ho capito semplice semplice una mazza
perché tanto poi le miss punta e mi
sento addosso ma quindi lei è sempre più
brutta delle altre c'è si vede dopo li
mortacci mi sa ke kazzo aran asse di
legno baraffa massei [ __ ] o lo fai
apposta o lo fai a poi non può essere
così stupida c'e veramente giorno
testimoni di geova o ecco la a6
sculettato che sei andata dall'altra
parte come fai ad essere qui spiegami
non mi salta ammazzerei il cugino ti
giuro tanto è inutile ragazze che guardo
doveva che tanto si nasconde dove gli
pare senti basta basta basta che rottura
ma quanto devo continuare a fa ste cose
togliti dalla forte togliete ma cos'è
ma cos'è diventato un gioco ai rock
veramente non ne posso più sono vivo per
miracolo tra l'altro devi morire e devi
mourinho ma che ti presso la madre
scrive per un filo la prossima volta ti
giuro oh mio dio un anno e mezzo per
falsa minchiata cioè è incredibile non
avete idea di quanto ci ho messo a
passano fatto mi ero di tagli che sono
io andrò questo non era un insegnante
tipo si avvicina allo specchio
questa era lo specchio quello del
vecchio 3 doubt non ricordo ancora che
spuntava il tipo dallo specchio
bruttissimo hai fatto il compleanno
bisogni rappresenta st candela siamo
tornati qui c'è il tipo che pulisce il
muro ma zio mai lercio il muro ma loro
vedi ragazzi da adesso infatti qualsiasi
cosa mi fa quel qualsiasi domanda
risponderò mai la risposta a tutto
regala veramente ha risposto a qualsiasi
cosa comunque ragazzoni miei ci sono un
botto distanze che io ho fatto la 106 mi
fate vedere so cosa cosa c'è nell'altra
102 salve oddio the grudge questo paese
è veramente lamentazioni di the grudge
incredibile permesso chiacchierato
ragazzi con quello che il primo episodio
di tre doubt visto che hanno fatto sta
cosa che ci sono otto stanze belle viva
sarà poco contento tantissimo comunque
spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa divide
piaciuto sull'argomento mi piace anche
la pace di facebook e come vi adottata
l'estizione a dimenticavo ragazzi mi
avete chiesto il discorso mettendo alla
maglia
ci avevo già messo nell'altro video mi
avete chiesto dove l'ho presa l'avevo
già detto ma lo ridico che si stava
ragazzine dai ragazzi nel carrefour
market è in tutti gli ipermercati
carrefour
così almeno sapete ed altri ragazzi
vendono anche la cover di una più [ __ ]
dall'altra che io ragazzi l'ho presa
però o leggermente sbagliato il modello
quindi me la infilo nel deretano è
quindi se avresti scritto che riuscivi
il diavolo prossimo video della ragazza